now a developing story where britain's
prince andrew has reached an
out-of-court financial settlement with
virginia giffrey this is the woman who
accused him of sexually assaulting her
20 years ago when she was 17 years old a
prince has for his part always denied
the allegations charlie angela in london
keeping an eye on this what's the
the details of this decision charlie
well lawyers for both guffrey and prince
andrew say that they have reached a
settlement and undisclosed some but also
that prince andrew will be making a
substantial donation to virginia
guffrey's charity that supports victims
rights and i do have the written filing
from prince andrew's lawyers which i
think is very interesting it says prince
andrew has never intended to malign ms
gouffrey's character he accepts that
she's suffered both as an established
victim of abuse and as a result of
unfair public attacks it is known that
jeffrey epstein
trafficked countless girls over many
years prince andrew regrets his
association with epstein and commends
the bravery of miss gufrey and other
survivors now it's safe to say that this
settlement has come completely out of
the blue in recent weeks the two sides
have been nothing but adversarial with
the duke of york's lawyers saying that
he wanted his day in court he wanted a
civil trial he wanted to be able to
stand up and give evidence under oath
and there was already a trial date
penciled in for between september and
december this year
in fact
prince andrew was due to give his
witness statement on march 10th which is
just over three weeks away so yes a very
surprising development in this case that
the two sides have uh settled with
prince andrew giving an undisclosed sum
to mr frey all right very carefully
worded statement wasn't that one
charlie regardless of this being a
settlement or whether it did go to trial
the damage that it has been done
obviously to to the victims but also to
the
wider royal establishment
absolutely it's worth remembering how
long this has been going on i mean the
allegations first surfaced in about
2015 when virginia guffrey
alleged that
prince andrew had assaulted her on three
separate occasions when she was just
seventeen uh prince andrew emphatically
denied these allegations um but guffrey
insisted that they were true saying that
she was put in this position by the
prince's friend jeffrey epstein who was
later convicted for trafficking girls
but the duke's consistent denials did
nothing to make this go away and it's
really hung heavy over the royal family
as a result he lost his right to use the
title royal highness he was stripped of
his military titles he was stripped of
uh his
his duties his in his service to the uk
as the royal family and the queen
tried to distance themselves very
publicly
from the scandal and the duke through
his legal team um
repeatedly said that the claims were
false and without foundation they tried
very hard to get it thrown out arguing
that because virginia guffrey had
successfully sued epstein in 2009
that
she could no longer pursue any other
individuals associated with the case but
of course the judge threw out that
argument but interestingly going back to
that statement this is the first time
that the duke has actually said he
regrets his association with epstein
which to many might sound quite
surprising that he didn't renounce his
friendship with a convicted pedophile
earlier but yet this is the first time
he said it so a change in tone there
from the duke obviously but the question
now will be whether or not he can
return to any form of public life
whether he would be allowed to by the
royal family whether he can rebuild or
would want to rebuild any kind of
reputation here in the uk come on
charlie angela thank you for that update